[Aplausos]
heredera de los proyectos familiares
marín le pain vivió desde pequeña de las
ideas de su padre jean-marie el fundador
del partido de extrema derecha frente
nacional
de niña defiende a su padre cada vez que
lo atacan
tras esto se vuelve una vocación ser
abogada pero no tarda en entrar en
política
a los 30 años en 1998 consigue su primer
mandato local en el consejo regional de
no para de cali el padre ve en ella su
relevo
comprometida empieza su misión suavizar
la imagen paternal y marcar una
diferencia
soy marine lepén siempre fui marine
lepén y siempre seré man independent no
soy un clon de mi padre
el 21 de abril de 2002 yo masri lepén la
hace llorar
ella se lo agradece su padre está en la
segunda vuelta contra jacques chirac
marín escala posiciones y en 2011 llega
a su momento de ahora en adelante ella
levanta el timón del barco familiar
consigna la des diabolización de su
frente nacional
seamos hombres mujeres cristianos judíos
musulmanes hetero somos somos antes que
nada franceses una estrategia eficaz la
base electoral crece en 2014 el partido
gana las elecciones europeas en las
municipales logra una decena de
alcaldías y más de 1500 cargos de
consejeros municipales llega el momento
de matar políticamente a su padre y lo
echa de su propio partido es la fractura
no se les vuelve a ver juntos
públicamente
la segunda vez que se presenta a las
presidenciales en 2017 marín iguala a su
padre pero pierde en la segunda vuelta
frente a emanuel y como conclusión para
ganar hay que reformar la casa empezando
por la fachada
adiós al frente nacional bienvenida a la
agrupación nacional y la idea de salir
del euro y de la unión europea relegada
al olvido la nueva línea se percibe
menos radical algo que no gusta a su
padre jean-marie
y todavía menos a su sobrina más río mar
y sol
una vez más la política un asunto de
familia
[Música]